alright are you ready I think by now you
kind of got the hang of it right
what do you know the same cause it's
quite straightforward with 10 so the
part that makes sense for tear is the
part between the asymptotes
hey like sir
and again my way Cory getting sick of
this phone 45 degree angle at the origin
anyway so what's the actual domain well
the asymptotes their equations of X
equals pound two and execute sorry -
pine - positive okay so that's gonna
translate to horizontal asymptotes for
the universe
okay question is increasing or
decreasing it's increasing right just
like this is increasing
should I put the origin there and this
is also going to be increasing so off
you go 45 degrees and okay no problem
now by the way because you will get
asked to do this when you're graphing
right just like we have 10x mrs. 10x but
you know in terms of appearance it looks
the same as to Tainos or 310 notice or
510 X right so therefore just like you
need to put the scale on here and the
standard is sort of like what 1 right
because 10 at 5 or 10 or 45 is work in
the same way you'd probably put you know
if you just go over some distance that's
prime for there so that's halfway
between 0 and pi/2 so that makes it easy
right so that's the inverse so let's
tidy all up so here's a table ok and we
did sign then we did cause and then we
did 10 ok so domain now which we think
you have the inverses now right so
remember when you had sign right that
was this guy so domain is the horizontal
values where it makes sense so what's
the domain
because what it came from right remember
like we in inverse rate domain of rain
came from the regular functions range
and domain because we've swapped
everything today okay
so therefore since the range of sign was
- what - like the domain of sign will be
minus 1 to 1
now just to skip ahead you know cos
inverse was the same guy basically but
sort of moved up and then turned around
okay so it's domain is still saying ok
but range changes doesn't it we went
from minus PI - it's a plan - yeah right
but here we saw if you took that domain
it wouldn't work right because that part
of cos looks like this it fails the
horizontal line test which is why we
went from 0 to 5 so just to draw back -
you know the first lesson when I said
you know we don't really get invest rate
functions so we use them but we like I
don't know like they do the job can you
see what's going on here this is the
reason why the side rule has an
ambiguous case but the cosine only
doesn't can you see the side rule if
you're using the sine rule in a triangle
like the Australian and suppose you had
another two single there okay and you
use the cycle to find out what that
angle was okay and you know suppose we
knew it was obtuse okay when he is sine
inverse when use the signs it can't tell
you that you saying why not it's outside
the domain so what would it give you if
it can't give you the obtuse angle that
it is what would it give you it gives
you the equivalent acute angle so you
know suppose this was 120 it would give
you thing okay and the reason for that
is because when you can get sine side of
120 is the same as sine thing okay the
values are the same
so sine has the same rule has an
ambiguous case but cosine doesn't if
it's an obtuse angle
it'll just tell you the obtuse angle
because cause embers can do that right
yeah oh yes sorry I made 150 150 I can't
take supplements yeah okay sorry
let me Terry all right but do you get
what's going on there right the reason
why the rules give you this I always
wonder why is it there's an empty use
case for Chris I mean this is why right
yeah it's not arbitrary there's a good
reason for it
okay tan inverse of the domain you can
see it there it just goes right because
for the original function tan if its
range was or we're evaluating right so
it stops around now just a little thing
to be careful about right the range of
tan inverse is very similar to the range
of sine inverse but it's not quite right
what's the difference yeah you can't get
these boundaries because they're asking
to us right so therefore - planets - let
them and not inclusive these additional
be Y actually until you stupid writing
X's and angles together okay make sense
yeah when I when I got taught chemistry
function this is where we started I
started with this table and it's like
memorize this I can also use it so I
heard now that you've seen where it's
all come from and why we you know why do
we restrict domains for inverse
functions it makes sense to you remember
a little bit off now tomorrow what we're
gonna do is work out what happens when
you mix together inverse trig functions
with the original functions so for
instance don't answer this if you think
you know the answer but just to think
about it are these two the same if they
are Y if they're not how are they
different
okay things like that and you know what
happens when you actually put no missing
there what happens when you mix them up
what if you take cos inverse cosine or
sine inverse of cos in
okay so that